Peter King joins us got a Belichick Ian
look to him today
check out Peters football morning shaky
football now me if it was bill a cheeky
and I'd have the sleeves cut off
wouldn't I
well that's a little breezy today yeah
now we can do that I can get one of the
guys in back now okay I like this
sweatshirt I got it a game three of the
World Series and what is uh Ryan
Zimmerman
it's the Ryan Zimmerman quote remember
this one I blacked out it and then we
want football morning in America must
read for every NFL fan at NBC Sports
done but for every human being on the
planet I don't think for everybody
oh alright okay for most people I think
because most people are football fans on
the planet how would you have benefit
you were a baseball writer instead of a
football I because it feels like you
love baseball more than you love
football I I don't know it's close but
here's the thing about baseball baseball
I think we can all watch it and all have
an idea right at that absolute moment
why in the world didn't AJ Hinch put
Gerrit Cole in Game seven yeah why why
and I love this comment where everybody
says well you know you don't want to
bring Garrett : in the middle of an
inning he's never been a relief pitcher
in his life what difference does it make
it's the same number of warmup pitches
if he comes in at the start of the
eighth or in the middle of the seventh I
I don't are we one out in the seventh I
don't really understand the logic and
look I think AJ Hinch is fantastic I
really think he's an excellent manager
you know I'm just right there he made a
mistake I would have left Greg Guillen
for one more batter yes has he thrown 80
pitches and because and because he had I
think it was the two in one count to
Juan Soto
he threw a perfect strike that the UMP
missed you know and and so it wasn't
like he had fallen apart after giving up
the home run he hadn't he walked a guy
and and he gave up four base runners in
set is six in a third or whatever it was
I don't know I just think he really had
a quick hook for a guy who was
dominating the game yeah I can't have
the best pitcher in baseball who is
still in the bullpen and he never comes
into the game and will Harris who was
running on fumes intently so hey
whatever thank you for coming in and
joining us here in the manor cave that
charger story got shot down quickly by
Dean Spanos yesterday yes was it a real
story you know Dan all I know is and
believe me I'm no chef teah or a
Rappaport or anything like that right
now in my life cuz I don't wake up in
the morning and see a piece of news like
that and make six phone calls you know I
just don't do that right now but I did
make two phone calls yesterday to ask if
it was real and to people who I feel or
plugged into it say it was absolutely
news to them so that's all I know it's
not it seems highly unlikely from this
standpoint the NFL is not going to put a
team in London until at the absolute
earliest 2022
so the Chargers have to go somewhere
they can't keep playing in a soccer
stadium for the next three years I mean
they've got to go somewhere so I think
it's I think it would be highly unlikely
that they wouldn't be playing in Los
Angeles but you can't send them to
Oakland they they're not going back to
San Diego there's there's sort of a I
think they're going to LA and they're
gonna they're probably gonna have a
bunch of empty seats early on and it'll
be in LA thing if they win people come a
couple other things you're Cam Newton
done for the rest of the year could we
see an Andrew Luck situation here no I
don't think that Cam Newton will
voluntarily walk away from what I know
of the situation I think Cam Newton
might might and you know the the
Panthers have four months before they
have to make this decision the start of
the league year basically
they might get a divorce from Cam Newton
but I am NOT taking that for granted at
all I just think it's a possibility they
could save a lot of money on the cap
like I don't know 17 or 18 million
dollars and Dan you have to remember
this if Cam Newton wherever he lines up
on opening day 2020 it basically will be
two years plus almost that he's been
healthy because remember last year he
had the shoulder thing almost the whole
year this year he comes in in late
August and gets the Liz Frank injury I
don't and and remember ice I talked to
him right at the end of July early on in
camp and he said flat out that I am
learning how to be a quarterback in a
different way so you know what are you
getting if you sign Cam Newton or what
are the Panthers getting if they bring
him back so I think it's a I think it is
definitely up in the air right now yeah
I think it makes sense for Carolina to
move on for a variety of reasons because
now you're gonna ask Cam Newton to be
something that he's not great at and
that's being I can't use my legs yeah
I'm not gonna be that kind of
quarterback now I'm gonna be a pocket
passer and I haven't been a great pocket
passer Kyle Allen is one of those guys
who just says okay this is what I'm able
to do I'm not gonna color outside the
lines yeah and it feels like they know
it's a match with Norv Turner yeah
that's what it is
and I will say this though Cam Newton
was very very Pro Norv Turner very in
the corner of becoming more of a classic
quarterback when I saw him in the summer
so we just don't know and the other
question is this this is why this was
such an important year for Newton
because we needed to see if he was gonna
be good at being that kind of
quarterback and we just don't know right
now if you're the Chicago Bears do they
chase Daniel right now but do you admit
you've admit you've made a mistake with
Mitchell true Biscay there's no there's
no you don't have to say a word you just
have to say we're giving Mitch
you know some downtime I you know look
at Dan I don't know what you think but I
watched a bunch of their game the other
day against Philly and you see and I'm
not saying that facial expressions tell
everything Mitchell to Biscay there were
times when they locked in on his face
where he looked like he was in an oral
oral surgeons chair without novocaine
and he just you know he this is this has
got to be incredibly uncomfortable for
imagine you're Mitchell true Biscay
you're you're a nice guy everybody loves
you you go to North Carolina you play
for one year and one year only and
you're pretty good
who knows how great you are because you
you you know you they haven't seen all
that much of you but a team chooses you
hi in the first round and it just
happens to be in Chicago and all the
fans want is for you to be better than
Jim McMahon and the next Michael Jordan
or something like that they want a
savior at quarterback and when you're
drafted number two overall there are
great expectations they would take rex
grossman right now well i don't know
about that but but but i but i'll say
this that i don't think that matt Negi
has to say a word
other than we just think this week right
now chase Daniel gives us a better
chance to win because right now listen
every time the Bears you know one more
loss right about now and I say it's over
but it's not over right now you know if
they win the next couple of weeks as
unlikely as it sounds they're still in
it and so I think you've got to do what
you what is the best thing for you to
win this game in this game only talking
to Peter King you can read his column
everybody in America in the world should
read it it's football
morning in America that's what I say
yeah every Monday at NBC sports.com if
you're the Eagles would you kick the
tires on Antonio Brown absolutely not no
way you lost to Sean Jackson you had I
don't care even but you get into
Brown you're you know you're casting
your fate to the wind you're you know
look we can talk about whether you think
he's guilty think he's innocent anything
like that but anybody who takes some in
my opinion just basically says that you
know we will that now the Patriots
signed him before the most grievous of
accusations came out okay now that those
accusations came out and obviously
you're innocent till proven guilty in
America but I just think right now if
you take him on your team and not only
that but he is a divisive figure that's
what he is he's a divisive figure I just
would not take the risk if I were the
Eagles give me the number of teams you
think who have a very good chance of
going to the Superbowl starting in the
AFC how many teams in the AFC do you
think have a solid chance to go to the
Super Bowl I would say as of today three
the Patriots the Ravens and the Chiefs
not the Texans well I mean I like the
Texans you say it's solid Jets yeah I
would put that I'd put them number four
and I would have a little bit of line a
line of demarcation after Kansas City
but we're assuming Kansas City with you
know with my home's coming back yeah
yeah in the NFC how many teams well the
NFC is is a complex place right now
because I still think that Green Bay is
in it I think that San Francisco and New
Orleans right now we're one in 1a and
then Green Bay and then I'm not sure if
I like Seattle or Dallas better but I
think Seattle and Dallas are close and
then I think the Rams but I'm not
counting Philadelphia out and I'm
dubious about Minnesota but Minnesota is
intriguing do you know who the Cowboys
are no because they always make they
make three or four mistakes every game
and you say why did that happen
you know the interception on the first
series the other day where you know
somehow someway dak Prescott doesn't see
Antoine Bethea and I don't know there's
some weird look dak Prescott is gonna
make a lot of money and rightfully so
but he's not immune from this stuff
either he makes he makes a few mistakes
and I think he's a very good player and
I would pay him and I would be happy to
pay him because I think he is incredibly
reliable and I like him a lot as a
person and a leader but he makes his
share of mistakes as well more likely to
be one-and-done gates or Freddie
kitchens I mean that's the question of
the day you change almost every Monday
on that one but my gut feeling is just
an absolute gut feeling as kitchens
because that was a game Sunday they
needed to win and Dan I did us a shart
in my column on Monday now we have the
exact perfect way to compare what
happened last year to this year because
last year Freddie kitchens took over
with 8 games left now now they have
played 8 games and the passer rating of
Baker Mayfield last year in the last
state was 106 the passer rating of Baker
may feel this year in the first eight
games is 71 how in the world with the
same coach and better personnel at skill
positions
how are you 35 quarterback rating points
worse than you were last year I want to
know now might one of my pet theories is
that has nothing to do with commercials
or anything like that but I think the
offensive line is is mediocre and
absolute best and it's not doing
Mayfield any favors but that is the
biggest damming thing about Freddie
kitchens right now why is the
quarterback playing like crap when you
had him last year and he was playing
great but I look at
and Arnold as well you know when you're
the quarterback whisperer and your
quarterback is regressing
I got a stressing significantly I think
that is a big look I think the Jets
probably have the worst offensive line
in football so that is a huge problem
for Sam dharna but I think the other
problem is you know look I understand he
had massive quarterback injuries in
Miami Tannehill couldn't stay healthy I
get it
but he went to Miami to develop the
quarterback position and he left it
probably in worse shape than when he
arrived and in his last 21 games he's 5
and 16 so I mean something has got to
change here in the last half of this
season I mean I was thinking about this
on my way over here today how about the
Giants and Jets playing Sunday how about
both fan bases wearing bags over their
heads I mean it could that could happen
how about we put a bag over the stadium
anybody watch this thing a side topic
here is anybody talked to Andrew Luck
recently not that I know of I probably
should try but I when he left somebody
who knows him just said you you won't be
hearing for me in to her luck this year
you know he's he's gonna go away and I
think you know it's so interesting what
happened I can't wait to have at one
point sometime in life a long
conversation with him because damn 19
days before he quit football he stood
there with me and he was damn excited
about this season and I just really want
to know what happened and why when he
did it did it seem like the weight of
Antarctica was off his shoulders yeah
and I don't hear Colts fans clamoring
for Andrew Luck because Jacobi
bruschettas played his quarterback it's
not the problem I mean there isn't a
problem they're a good tne or they're a
good team but I agree I mean Jacobi
Brissette was in have was in a unique
position first of all he's pretty good
and he took almost every snap
all offseason with the ones they were
used to playing football with Jacoby
percent not Andrew Luck and not not that
not that Andrew Luck wouldn't have been
better this year I'm not saying that but
this guy was in a perfect position and I
can tell you legitimately I know Frank
Reich well he loves Jacoby percent and
rightfully so
Jacoby Bru said you know there's a
couple of these quarterbacks who could
be like a like a secondary if you're
giving out a secondary MVP this year
Teddy Bridgewater Kyle Allen yeah
Jacoby brusett like guys who weren't
gonna win it yeah but if you had that
these are guys who have been as valuable
to their penny Bridgewater was
unbelievable and totally changed
everybody's view of who Teddy
Bridgewater is nobody knew anything
about him he hadn't played football in
four years and he comes out and he shaky
the first couple of games when he wins
and then he starts playing Sean Payton
and he start getting comfortable with
each other and that was a phenomenal run
that he had and great for him and now
I'll tell you who takes Teddy
Bridgewater
next year okay who does it is it you
know if I were the Bears I'd go hard
after Teddy Bridgewater I would love to
have that guy on my team not only to be
quarterback but to try to save Mitchell
true Biscay and Teddy Bridgewater would
do it he would help true Biscay he is a
selfless guy he's like he's like this
generations Josh McCown he's a good good
human being now he wants the job yeah
and he would try to beat him beat him
back for the job but he would help true
Biscay thanks for coming in Pete thanks
Dan to see you think it's the column
that everybody in the world is reading I
love Dan
I love Dan you are like an Istanbul yes
you're yes killing history books yes
I play risk Sri Lanka and you can't go
anywhere without seeing that column
football morning in America it's every
Monday at NBC Sports calm for more Dan
Patrick
tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]